[Music]
good morning everybody thanks for
joining us here at Google next my name
is Matt Leonard I'm a product manager in
the Google cloud billing platform before
joining Google cloud and joined the
billing team here I actually worked in
billing at asher and AWS so kind of
somewhat a you call a self-inflicted
billing cloud expert unfortunately today
we want to talk about like financial
governance for managing your cloud
business so I think most of us here in
the IT industry can agree that cloud has
disrupted the way that we manage our
business and how we go about procuring
and managing infrastructure we're
focusing on spamming has changed the way
that we buy our infrastructure in a
traditional model it's a very
centralized processes controlled its
predictable everything's run to a budget
cycle we have financial controls checks
and balances to ensure that spending
doesn't get out of control the clouds
disrupted that anyone in your company
with access can now spin up instances
that you don't have any visibility to
and you end up reacting to cost rather
than planning for it this IT spending
it's moved from a capex expense which is
predictable over a long period of time
to an optics expense which is is coming
in on a monthly basis and and you're
managing and trying to control that
spanned so to play on this metaphor you
wouldn't build a ship that's full of
holes and you don't want to approach
your cloud billing in the same way you
need a plan you need a strategy for your
financial governance lack of financial
governance in the cloud can be kind of
shocking if it happens to you as an
organization I have a couple of examples
that I wanted to share of incidents that
I've been involved with in my years of
working in cloud billing we are we had a
customer recently that was doing a
loading scale test they spun up 9,000
instances ran the load test a few days
later they realized they hadn't switched
up the environment
oops it was an expensive expensive
problem to have I also work with an ISP
at one point they were they were doing a
solution that they wanted to run on
multi-cloud so they'd use cloud
formation on AWS and they spun up their
templates and the way that cloud
formation works is when you do a
deployment and that deployment fails
cloud formation is stateful and it rolls
back the resources they then went over
to Azure and they started using our
templates now launching instances and
off they go
well aam is not stable it doesn't
rollback instance in the in a failed
deployment this customer ended up with a
$350,000 bill for Asia because they
weren't watching this fend but this
doesn't have to be a reality your
reality can be much more controlled and
predictable
we had another customer recently that
they're basically application engineer
checked in some code didn't normal run
rave for the storage expenses on this
application was about points or a full
percent of their applications
cost per file it went to 45 percent of
a9 luckily they were monitoring this
they had controls in place they sort of
changed the application profile were
able to change rollback that code and
control their expense
so that's what we had data talked about
what tools we have in the Google cloud
toolkit that are gonna help you with
your financial governance strategy then
we have Lukas here from the brode he's
gonna talk about how they managed to did
scale for their business excuse me sorry
so some of the quick questions you need
to ask yourself when you think about
your financial governance strategy is
how is my cost organized if you if you
attended the session earlier James why
is the decision called and so I'm just
gonna make sure I get it right here
managing costs and GCP how to structure
your resources and this this laid out
some of the best practices and so if you
didn't if you weren't able to attend
that I suggest that you catch it online
but it talks about some of the different
mechanisms that you have in Google cloud
to organize your cost so we have folders
we have projects and we have labels and
those are different mechanisms by which
you can organize your cost either in
structured hierarchy or in a
cross-cutting and cross-project way but
it's pretty important because that's
what you're going to bind all your
financial governance policy to how you
organize cost and you're probably not
going to want to look at it at a single
level you're gonna want to look at it by
project which probably represents a team
or an application or an environment but
you might want to also look at it by
organization I have a department I want
to see how much this departments costing
a totality so want to monitor at
multiple levels second what is my budget
this is really important
how much do I actually expect to spend
so we're gonna look at like where have I
been how much does it cost me in the
past where is it going in the future
like how is my cost projected at the
current run right and then what if what
if we changed the the characteristics of
this application change the profile the
machines that we're using what if we had
a 4x increase in in the amount of
traffic that's going to hit this
platform we want to play out some of
these scenarios so that we can
understand what is my budget and and how
am I going to manage that and then
lastly what is that what is the budget
impact this is kind of an interesting
one what would you want to do when you
get to your budget the most passive form
of impact is I'm going to just notify
some people I'm going to let you know
that something's happening that you
weren't expecting but it can be much
much more intrusive you hear I hear
customers a lot who talk about capping I
want a cap actually I'm fine if you
delete all my resources you blow away
all my storage and and you make this
never exist because I don't want to pay
another penny and like us we'll talk
about some of those use cases himself
actually because it's something that you
hear in devtest environments and
students where they actually can't pay
another penny and so they need to stop
that cost more than likely you probably
have a strategy somewhere in between
oops
so oops I skipped slide no I did not I
swear goal here at Google cloud is to
give you a toolkit because there is no
one-size-fits-all what you run in your
production environment may be very very
different to what you want to put in a
sandbox environment so that people can
play around with the cloud so we want to
give you lots of different options so
today we're gonna talk about a few
different tools and toolkit we're going
to talk about permissions we got to talk
about quota and we're going to talk
about budget and how you can use those
in your business and then Lucas is going
to give you some real-life examples some
permissions I'm just gonna explain this
diagram for a little bit because I'm
being told that it's a little bit
distracting with the way it keeps
spinning essentially you want to operate
an environment of least privilege um so
you can see here in this diagram that
effectively a user is allowed to access
resources
launch them unless permission denies it
the way that you use lease privilege is
going to differ again between like your
production environment and a sandbox
environment in your production
environment you might have a very strict
permissions model where only a few users
can access and launch resources in that
production environment but you may have
somewhat of a loose of financial
governance model where you don't want to
terminate resources you don't want to
cap spending you just want to be
notified it's a lot more passive whereas
in your sandbox environment you might
want a very strict financial governance
policy that says I want to terminate
these resources when my cost gets to foo
or you can only launch so many different
instances but you may have a very loose
permissions model anybody can spin up
one of these non production accounts as
long as it's financially goand quota
quota quota basically enables you to
build a virtual datacenter it basically
sets the maximum concurrent resources
that you can operate now today the way
that quota operates is essentially by
SKU and so an example of that is the
number of cores that you can launch for
compute so if you set a quota control
that says I have a hundred cause that's
kind of like a physical data center
where you can only put so many VMs into
a rack and you're going to put it so
many racks into a physical data center
and so you've actually controlled the
maximum amount of resources that a user
can spin up and so therefore you've
controlled the cost it's not going to be
more than a hundred Bitcoin or whatever
a hundred VMs will cost you because
you've max maximize the amount that they
can spend now they might not spend a
hundred cores but they can spend it up
to 100 cores now if it's a dev test
environment and somebody's just playing
around with with the environment you
might want to set that to three for
example which is a very low number and
you know that you're not going to have a
large cost spin out so this is kind of
what a quarter environment looks like
right now there's lots of interesting
things that'll be coming down the track
here that we can we can talk about in a
Q&A session if you're interested but
basically that that quota enables you to
throttle your total spend but you have
to think about what that does to your
environment if it's production
environment is it okay for you to have
that degradation and performance if you
hit the hundred cause things are going
to slow down or if you're in bigquery
and you have a maximum amount of slow
it's queries gonna sit and they're gonna
wait waiting for a slot to open up to
run and so quotas great but you have to
think about how that impacts your
business last we gonna talk about
budgets budgets enable you to normalize
usage across everything that we have in
cloud wood today we have a lot of SKUs
close to 100,000 SKUs if you if you want
to look at in the myriad detail across
all the different regions and different
products and different ways that you can
spin things up and and what budget
allows you to do is normalize it into
cost of a time so it becomes very simple
and and you can decide what you want to
do as you hit your budget limits today
and in Google Cloud we let you monitor a
monthly budget per project to a per
billing accountant so you can specify
that and you can get a simple
notification when you hits preset
threshold so you could say I have a
hundred Bitcoin to spend when I get a 50
Bitcoin I want you to tell me because I
want to see how I'm trending you can
also automate budget actions we recently
launched a new feature called
programmatic notifications this
essentially allows you to build your own
budget policy now eventually we want to
bring this so it's a function of the
console but today what this allows you
to do is is to specify in a cloud
function like a different set of actions
and we provide some basic reference
architectures which Lucas will go into
in a bit more detail but you can do
things like you can Ford your budget
notification to different mediums like
slack or you can suspend resources we
gave an example policy of how to take a
budget notification and shut down all
the compute instances or you can cap
spending you can actually pull a project
out of a billion count that which will
farm out a termination of all resources
in that billing account and so this is a
fairly powerful tool with a fairly
simple implementation I had a customer
recently told me it took them about
seven minutes to set it up so fairly
straightforward all right without
further ado I'm gonna introduce lukas
from the burden he's gonna talk about
how they operate at scale thank you Matt
let's see here
okay I'm Lukas Carlson I work at the
Broad Institute I have going backwards
here I've been with the brode for a
little over 15 years I started
exactly two weeks after the bird
Institute completed the human genome
project in 2003 and over the last 15
years we've sequence something like a
hundred thousand genomes after that
first one I started as a Systems
Administrator and sort of moved into a
manager of systems administrators and
then I became a bit of a software
engineer writing web applications and
other automation tools and at some point
we needed to create a DevOps group so I
took two years or so and created a
DevOps group with abroad and now I'm
responsible for our cloud environment
and for the success of our developers in
using that environment if you don't know
about the broad we're a Research
Institute doing bioinformatics and
biologies type stuff in Cambridge
Massachusetts as I mentioned we were one
of the major contributors for the human
genome project we also have a bunch of
other things that you might have heard
of for example something recent that
we've worked on is the CRISPR patent for
editing genomes and we're organized
around major major research areas and
major sort of production services so for
example we have a group that's focusing
entirely on cancer research we have
another group that's focusing entirely
on psychiatric disease research like
depression and bipolar and then the
platform's run like small businesses
within the Institute that provide a
production service so for example the
genomics platform provides services
around extraction of DNA storing DNA
sequencing DNA and analyzing DNA we're
funded from a number of different
sources so for example we have dozens
and dozens of different government
grants for different projects that we're
working on and each of those grants
obviously have certain constraints on on
how many resources they they grant we
have lots of different philanthropic
gifts as well and today actually
philanthropy has changed a little bit so
people don't have a tendency as much to
just give money into places they sort of
do this venture philanthropy where
they're like investing in a particular
scientific outcome so we have a lot of
those kinds of gifts and then we have
some inventions
like crisper and some software licensing
and stuff that we do that brings in some
revenue as well now when we're talking
about the cloud there's a bunch of
things that we're concerned about as I
mentioned because so much of our
research is funded by government grants
we have to be very thoughtful about how
we use those funds it's public funds for
first and second you know there's a lot
of constraints so a given grant might
only have a certain amount of money
available to it over a certain time
period and then only a portion of that
grant is what's going to be used for the
cloud computing a lot of it might be
used for the sequencing or other parts
of the process and when we do overspend
on one of these grants it's a real
problem because if you have a grant that
has ten thousand dollars of resources
and you mistakingly spend a hundred
thousand dollars well that grant is not
gonna pay the extra ninety thousand that
you spent we have to pull that from some
other place and we can't pull it from
another grant so we have to pull it from
like our administrative funds that we
used to sort of run the business now
when we're using the public cloud
there's some things that we're
particularly concerned about you have a
lot of issues that can come up that can
affect the way you spend money so for
example as Matt alluded to you can have
developers who are spinning up instances
and they just leave them running and a
month later you look at your bill and
you're like why did I spend tens of
thousands of dollars and it's a oopsie
situation
we also use a lot of storage storage is
probably 60 or 70% of our overall cost
of using the cloud so when we make a
choice to put a bunch of storage into a
global bucket instead of maybe a near
line or cold line bucket if that's the
way we intend to use it that can
drastically change the cost and so we
want to be able to keep an eye on that
kind of stuff and really track it so we
make good decisions we also periodically
have problems where people know that
they don't have enough resources to do
the work that they want to do and do it
anyway and so they come and they ask for
forgiveness about this overspend issue
and we're still having to take the money
from somewhere else in order to pay for
that so that's a real big issue
something that can happen is
periodically you will have a developer
make a mistake like committing one of
their service accounts JSON keys
to a public github repo this is a great
experiment if you want to see how
quickly crypto miners can find your key
get into your project and spin up lots
of instances and so many of you who use
the cloud may have run into situations
like that and so monitoring your cost is
very important because that's even worse
than the developer who spun up a VM and
forgot to shut it down because they're
literally going to use all of the quota
that you have to try to make as much
crypto as possible over the smallest
period of time
and a lot of these issues when you're
thinking about moving a large
institution from your on-prem
environment into the cloud they can
create a real obstacle to being
successful because all these people who
are responsible for these grants if they
have a very controlled and understood
way of managing their resources in the
on-prem sort of legacy environment and
they don't have that in the cloud then
that creates a real fear and uncertainty
about moving to the cloud I know when I
run jobs in our on-prem environment
exactly how much it's gonna cost if I go
do it in the cloud and I make some you
know mistake
am I gonna spend all the Broads money
that's a big concern and that has a lot
of people sort of second-guessing the
move to the cloud and so we want to
solve that so most of the talks that I
give as a cloud architect of the Broad
Institute have to do with scale and so I
want to talk about what I mean when I
talk about scale in our GCP environment
so many of you you know if you use G
suite you might have one G suite domain
if you use GCP you might have one
billing account maybe you have dozens of
projects potentially but where is sort
of another order of magnitude here so
for example we have seven individual G
suite domains two of which are
production domains and part of the
reason for that is we have a cloud
service called firecloud which is hosted
on Google and it provides facilities for
researchers around the world to do
genomic analysis and the team that
manages that system part of the
application uses route credentials in
the G suite domain to create groups and
create users and so we don't want to
give out the credentials for the broad
Institute's domain
to the team that's building the software
package so they have their own domain
for firecloud and then we have a bunch
of test domains and quality and QA and
other things that that we use different
G suite domains for across these seven
domains primarily in our main domain
broad institute org we have over 5,000
users and this is interesting because we
only have around 1,400 employees so it
turns out that we're a very
collaborative and open institute and
there are thousands of people from our
sister institutions around Cambridge and
the Harvard teaching hospitals and such
where they also have identities in our
environment and they can log into our G
suite they can even log into our
clusters they can use the cloud and so
forth so it's a very very large
environment as far as the number of
users and it's also very spread out
because they're not all within our
buildings we have 2,500 groups which is
about you know one group for every two
users and there's we are set up in a way
that users can create their own groups
so there's quite a few of them and we
use those to manage google dot
permissions to manage access to GCP
projects Google Sites any number of
things in addition to mailing lists
which many of you may use them for now
four of those G suite domains have a
corresponding GCP org that's in use
there's one for the broad institute
which our users when they create
projects as you mentioned users can can
create projects and spin up resources
they create their projects in the Broad
Institute to a man but firecloud
actually creates projects as part of its
process when a new user signs up for
firecloud and creates workspaces and
starts doing genomic analysis there are
projects that are created in the
background by service accounts that are
used by that system and those are
created in organization organizations
that are specific to that domain in
order to organize all the things in
these organizations we have a lot of
folders and we can apply permissions and
other controls at the folder level and
at the subfolder level and this turns
out to be dozens and dozens approaching
200 folders at this point we have over
7,000 projects which becomes really
challenging to manage even if you just
want to get a list of all your projects
and
see the I am permissions on each one
that can be sort of an involved endeavor
and maybe there's only around 800 or so
in our G suite in our primary Broad
Institute oh man and the rest of them
are all part of the firecloud system a
slide here says that I have 75,000
buckets that's actually incorrect I
learned this week that we have a test
project that has 280,000 buckets in it
and it's just most of my systems that
monitor the project's fail on that one
and I only learned that this week so
that should say that we have 320,000
buckets and in those buckets
we have over 35 petabytes nearly 40
petabytes of storage today and that's
about half of what we have overall
because we have about that same amount
in our legacy on-prem environment that
we're still are trying to figure out how
exactly to move to the cloud and now
we'll get into the interesting part with
the building we have one billing account
which is pretty normal and like many of
you are billing account is a typical
monthly invoice billing account but we
have a configuration on our account that
we're set up kind of like a reseller
some of you may work with resellers to
purchase your GCP and we're set up like
that because we sort of resell the
service to our internal organizations
and I'm gonna go into this in a lot more
detail shortly this slide shows a bunch
of the features that we use within GCP
that help with managing everything at
scale I'm actually not going to go
through this because I'm gonna do pretty
much a slide for each one of those so
the billing accounts I mentioned the
monthly invoicing I mentioned on offline
contract I highly recommend if you have
a business that you're running on GCP
look into paying for it on an invoice
instead of using your credit card
because there are certain things that
can happen with the credit card we've
had an issue where someone used the
credit card to purchase something online
and they mistyped the zip code and then
the credit card company shut down the
card and so any other services that were
associated with that card would have
problems and so we certainly don't want
that to happen to our GCP environment so
the way we use these sub accounts let me
talk about that a little bit each one of
these grants and each one of our
internal cost structures we call them a
cost object some people call them a cost
Center an account
each one of those that wants to use the
cloud gets a sub account and the reason
we do this is because at the end of the
month and we get our one bill from
Google which we pay and then we charge
back to dozens and dozens of internal
cost objects the sub portion of the bill
that they actually spent so we were
originally doing this two or three years
ago using labels which I'll talk about
briefly and another slide but the
problem with using labels for this today
is that even if you create a project and
put a label on it that says which cost
Center it should be billed to the owner
of that project can change that or they
can remove the label and so if you rely
on that as a way of carving up your bill
then when you get the bill you go
what is this huge amount that doesn't
have a cost object and who should pay
for that and so that was very
problematic and so two years ago or so
we moved to this sub-accounts feature
again which is specifically geared
towards resellers and I think in the
future there might be some other models
that are coming that would actually be
more appropriate for us maybe around
using the folders for example so another
thing about these is that each one of
these cost objects is owned by somebody
there may be the the principal
investigator on the grant the person
who's responsible for the funds and they
may actually have more than one cost
object that they manage so if any of you
managed billing accounts in Google when
you manage more than one billing account
some of the things around budgets and
around permissions can get pretty
complicated and I'll talk about how we
work through some of that but the nice
thing about the bill that we get is that
it has one total at the bottom which is
the amount we pay and then it has one
hundred and seventy-five subtotals which
is the amount we charge all the internal
cost objects and we used to have to
calculate that ourselves so that has
actually a great benefit for us many of
the other great features that we use to
manage all this is the bigquery and the
JSON or CSV export we use both of these
right now the bigquery export is the
most valuable and that is the newest of
these features the CSV our JSON export
is useful for example some of you may
use a third-party service to help
visualize your billing across from
multiple clouds we've used tools like
cloud health for example in the past and
they
can easily consume your billing
information from a bucket with a CSV and
they were doing that for years because
that's how Amazon delivers its bills for
example and so now some of the companies
are starting to be able to use the
bigquery export for that too one of the
nice things about the bigquery export is
all the data related to your bill is
being piped directly into bigquery so
whatever tools you might use to deal
with bigquery you can use to do this so
when we want to visualize this data try
to understand what's going on in there
we have like half a dozen different ways
we can do that and some of these I'm
going to show in my demo a little later
so for example in the billing console
there's a new feature that came out this
year called billing reports and this
allows you to see a graph of all of the
activity and to narrow it down by SKU
and by product and by time period and
that for me actually is the best and
most common way that I like to look at
the bill today before that existed
though we used a lot of different
methods of looking at the data in
bigquery so for example we used Cloud
Data Lab which is like ipython jupiter'
notebooks that Google Offers you can
write you know reports and display
graphs and so forth about your billing
data that was very useful for us to
determine things like how much data we
have because you can't do you all your
buckets when you have 380,000 of them or
whatever so it's sometimes easier to
actually look at the billing data to
calculate how much data you have data
studio is also an amazing tool for this
this is relatively recent addition as
well but I absolutely love this if
you're familiar with Google sheets and
making like a chart and Google sheets
the user experience of doing data
analysis in data studio is very similar
to that it's it's quite easy and it's
it's a free service offered by Google
and then if the probe were also a big
tableau shop we have a lot of investment
in tableau and a lot of expertise in
tableau so we've built some very
complicated and in-depth reports to sort
of understand our GCP data using tableau
as well another useful feature is custom
I am rules we have one very important
custom I am role that we use right now
there's a few others that we have built
but this is probably the most useful we
have an individual in the procurement
department who is the person that
creates new Google billing accounts and
people are not allowed to create billing
accounts except for Stewart he has that
access and so basically the way the
process works is a user will say they
would like to begin using the cloud they
will specify which cost object they
would like to use and they will specify
some initial budgets like I am I want to
spend $100 a month or less and then
Stewart will go and he'll create the
billing account and he'll give them
access to the billing account and he'll
create that initial budget and then
he'll he'll share it with them so that
they can begin using it so in order to
grant him access to all of the billing
accounts we moved all of the billing
accounts into our GCP organization and
then we apply this permission at the org
level and so stewart inherits this
custom permission at the org level for
all of our resources and so what these
three permissions do we give him billing
account creator which i think is pretty
obvious but it allows him to create new
billing accounts and he's the only one
that can do that we also give him
billing account administrator so that
means he can change the names of the
billing accounts if necessary he can add
or remove administrative users on the
account and the project billing admin
permission is also very important
because it means he can move any project
in the organization from one billing
account to another which you can't do
unless you have both access to the
project and access to the billing
account so I mentioned the org and the
folders a little bit you know we do have
to production organizations one for
firecloud and one for Broad Institute
and then we have a few test
organizations that we use that as well
the way we've organized our folder
structure is not consistent but we use
different mechanisms depending on the
needs in a given situation so for
example the first thing that we do for
all of our billing accounts is we create
a corresponding folder in the
organization to map to that billing
account this does a few things for us
first of all I'm anticipating a future
where I might be able to actually apply
the billing
to the projects using the folder that's
not a thing yet but in a perfect world
for us we would like to be able to
organize projects into folders and then
have everything in that folder inherit
the building from the parent it makes it
easier for us to manage so that's
something we've been anticipating
so we've organized our organization so
it's ready for that so even though I
think I started that like maybe two
years ago whenever that feature exists
we will be ready to start using it
coming soon oh yeah okay so we have a
few organizations that are big GCP users
the IT organization which I'm involved
in is one of those organizations and so
we have hundreds of projects amongst us
and it's become useful to have folders
and subfolders so for example I have a
folder for the IT department and then I
have subfolders for the teams within
there and the managers of each of those
teams have the right access on the
folder so they can put things in the
folder and they can have permission over
all their stuff one of the other
benefits actually of the billing folders
that I didn't mention is that there's an
interesting thing if you are a billing
administrator and you own a billing
account because you're responsible for
the money you may not really be the
person who actually does anything in GCP
so you may delegate another person on
your team to have billing account user
permission and that allows that person
to create as many projects as they want
on your billing account it's sort of
analogous to giving someone a credit
card on your account and letting them do
whatever they want with it
the unfortunate thing about that is if
that person who makes that project on
your billing account does not give you
access to the project you have literally
no idea what your money is being spent
on so we have people contacting IT being
like what is on the money in here and
I'm like I don't know one of your people
made that can you talk to them and so we
it turns out it's much easier if we give
the billing account administrator the at
least viewer level access on the folder
and if all the folders excuse me if all
the projects that are associated with
that billing account are somewhere
beneath that folder then magically the
billing account administrator also has
access to see everything that their
people are creating which is a huge win
and then there's some situations where
you
I use folders for other purposes for
example if I have one very sensitive
project that I only want a few people to
access and all the rest of the projects
I want a larger number of people to
access I might at the top level have
those as two separate top level folders
that way I can have a very restrictive
folder that only inherits a limited
amount of permissions and I may be
applying no permissions at the top level
in that situation that way your
sensitive projects can go in that
sensitive high-level folder and the
other things can go elsewhere so we use
that in a few places quotas I won't talk
about too much for a couple of reasons
one is if your quotas are high enough
then they're not really guardrails to
protect you so for example if you have a
project where you next week you're going
to need to run a job that uses 50,000
VMs and you raise your quota to 50,000
VMs then now that's what your quota is
set to so that's not going to prevent
you from spending a lot of money if you
leave those 50,000 VMs running
indefinitely you're certainly gonna
spend a lot of money on that and so when
you run at the scale that we do and your
quotas have to be as high as ours are
they turn out not to be as protective
and so again I mean this is something
that I would like to deal with
differently and so I've been envisioning
the idea of being able to control this
at those folder levels like as I
mentioned so you know maybe if I had at
the folder level the ability to control
which quota assigned to which things
that would be more useful for us and so
again we're hoping for a future where
that is a true thing so I think this is
my last slide the the budgets and
notifications are probably why I'm here
to talk with you all today and so we
have dozens and dozens budgets each one
of the billing accounts has one or more
budgets on it
if you've used this feature if you use
billing accounts and budgets then up
until earlier this year the only way you
would get notified about these things
was via email and if you're like me and
you happen to be a billing administrator
on a hundred and seventy-five billing
accounts
then the number of notifications you get
from Google about a budget that is over
a threshold is a lot it's multiple times
a day and I certainly can't react to all
of those in a sensible way so mostly I
ignore them which is a problem so the
addition of pub/sub notifications
basically changes all this and this has
been extremely exciting for me because
I've been working with Google on this
billing stuff for a few years and I've
like come up with ways to like read all
the emails and try to automatically
react to the emails but that is not a
scalable model so this pub/sub thing is
really great and I'm actually attempt to
show a demo of this and we'll see if it
actually does what I want but the
purpose here would be that you can send
these notifications to a cloud function
and then you can have that cloud
function wired up to do things that you
want in certain situations so for
example if there's a budget and I know
that if that budget hits a certain
threshold that there's an action I know
I want to take I could wire this up with
cloud functions and I've attempted to do
that here and I'm not super confident
but I'll show you as best I can and then
the final thing that I'll mention is
that we've built a bunch of little
custom tools using Google's api's using
iam api's and the cloud resource manager
and the billing API s and others to sort
of automate a lot of the stuff that we
do so I'm gonna try and show a couple of
those there's an app that I built like a
week ago which is the first one I'm
going to show it's very simple it just
sort of recreates Stewart's job of
creating and managing all the billing
accounts and and then I'm gonna show
this other App Engine app that I made
that's whole purpose is to try and deal
with these budget notifications and
that's where I'm a little more skeptical
about whether or not it's going to work
before I show the demo I'm gonna talk
about the architecture of this billing
notifications app have a bunch of logos
up here I'll see if I can make sense of
this for you so on the left hand side
you see in red the master billing
account that is the Broads normal
billing account we got a bill each month
from that thing and underneath that you
see there's several sub accounts
so each of those sub accounts has one or
more budgets and those budgets are all
wired up to send their information their
notifications to the same pub/sub topic
so we have one pub subtopic that is
receiving a barrage of notifications
they come in you know maybe a couple
times an hour for every single budget so
where you're normally getting notified
via email let's say once a week or
something I don't know exactly the
frequency these are coming in all the
time every hour and so whether or not
you've hit one of the thresholds you
know like the state of each of your
budgets at any given time so those all
feed into cloud pub/sub and then there's
this function at the bottom there that
consumes all the input from that cloud
pub/sub and it does some stuff like it
stores the the budget information in a
datastore database so I can look at any
given time and see the status of all 175
budgets without having to click through
175 different billing accounts it logs
it in cloud logging so I know what
happened and then it uses sort of a
lookup tool to try and figure out if it
should take an action and if it
determines that it should take an action
then it kicks off one of these other
cloud functions on the right there I
have one called disable billing one
called stop compute instances and one
called notify slack and each of those
does you know basically what it says it
does and there's a couple of other icons
on there I use bigquery because I like
to look at how much spend we've had up
to this point in the year that's like a
helpful little thing to look at when
you're looking at the budget and the
spun that's useful and then the cloud
resource manager because one of the
things this app does is it visits each
billing account to get all of the IAM
permissions and see who the users are
associated with that again that is an
operation that takes a while and so I
cache that data so I have easy ability
to report on who's associated with all
of our billing accounts and the App
Engine app you know users can log in and
it uses the identity aware a proxy to
make sure that only brode users log in
and the nice thing is since I know which
users are associated which with which
billing accounts I can show them only in
the billing accounts that relate to them
first let me wake up my computer
um type in my password then we are gonna
switch to the demo great um okay so this
app here is a simple little app that I
just built it last week so it only does
Google right now but it'll do other
things soon it is a list of all I guess
there's a hundred and eighty-eight
billing accounts now so my slides out of
date already some of them are disabled
then we just billing accounts don't have
a ton of things like labels or other
stuff so we have to use the actual name
of the billing account so when I take a
billing account that I'm not using
anymore and stop using it I changed the
name to disabled so this is really
useful you have a list of all the
billing accounts you know which cost
object it's linked to you can tell if
it's open or closed and you can jump to
the console for that particular billing
account and I have one that I actually
made specifically for this demo which is
gonna come into play in a moment another
thing this app can do is it as a list of
all of our invoices I'm not showing
anything useful here because this
actually doesn't do anything yet but the
premise of this app is that because it
knows which billing accounts or
associated with cost objects and because
Stuart can use it to create new billing
accounts the idea is it will also be
used to generate the internal charges
and we use sa P so at some point this
will calculate the bill each month and
split it across multiple things and
generate the totals we've had a bunch of
users recently who they have a more
complicated spending situation so
instead of using one cost object for
their project and all the money charges
to that one cost object they need to
split the funds across many different
cost objects which has become
complicated so part of what this system
does is allow for that so for example
this group here every month they split
whatever spend they had across 13
different cost objects and so this is
not something that Google supports
currently and the way we're using
these billing accounts so we have to
create a whole structure for this and
there's a few other useful tools here
like because we know all the cost
objects and what's affiliated with them
we can do some checking and see like
which billing accounts don't have a cost
object or apparently all these billing
accounts the cost object has expired
that's really fun for us because we get
the bill we process the bill and then we
go to charge all the internal cost
objects back and then we turn turns out
like ten or twelve of them are over and
we have to figure out what the new cost
object is so this is finally a way that
Stuart in one place can see all of that
information and can react to it and
again like this doesn't do much today
but with Stuart wants to create a new
billing account he can just click there
he can create one that's directly
associated with a specific cost object
or he can create one that it has a split
so now the other thing I want to show is
this thing that does all of the
notifications so as a user at the broad
if I were to log into this I would just
see my own billing account so this demo
account only has one billing account and
that only has two budgets but if I log
in as myself then I have several billing
accounts and a bunch of different
budgets and I can see them all in one
place which is really useful now there's
a thing on here that I kind of created
that most of this is just printing out
the data that comes from those budget
notifications but this projection column
is sort of something that I added in
typically if any of you use Google
billing accounts and you get these
alerts you have to sort of know what the
date is to know whether you care so if I
get an alert that says I'm over 50% on
my budget you know if I look at my watch
and I see that today is the second of
the month well that's a huge problem but
if today is the 24th and I do not care
at all and I don't even need that
notification so what I've done is I've
tried to sort of predict in a lazy way
like how much the budget is going to be
at the end of the month which is what
you really care about and so you know if
you're at 50%
today's the 24th and you're really not
and I had anything so it's nothing to
worry about but if it's like the second
day of the month and you're already at
50% then it's a big problem and so that
graph kind of shows how likely you are
to go
over your budget at the end now I'm
gonna skip through some of this because
the most important thing here is to show
the notifications so I'm going to show
you the key features I'd have to do with
that so in addition to a list of all the
billing accounts in here which is very
important um apparently ticking it's
sweet time to load I have a list of
actions that I've invented and so
there's four right now only three of
them work but it's the same things matt
mentioned earlier i can notify slack
instead of email i can stop the compute
instances which is sort of a big hammer
but not as big as the last one which is
to turn off billing entirely and then I
have these thresholds that I can define
in here to say well when this particular
budget hits this particular limit I want
to take this specific action and it's
very simple I only have one budget in
here and it only has the three actions
to find but I should be able to demo
this if things go well here so because
this all uses pub/sub I'm not actually
gonna spend the next 30 minutes waiting
for my account to hit the budget and
then to notify pub/sub I can just send a
pub/sub message to sort of fake that so
I'm gonna do that here so let's say that
this particular budget has hit 80% which
currently that's the only attribute I'm
triggering on is which threshold you
have exceeded I could also trigger off
of the budget amount for example I mean
know the cost amount for example but
it's not doing that today okay so I
posted this new pub/sub message let's
see what happened
maybe it'll take a moment mm-hmm next
Wi-Fi yeah great
nothing happened let's try this again am
I in the correct project no I am NOT
that's the problem here we go
okay I'm searching for this string let's
see what it says still nothing let's
just look okay well my logging is not
telling me what I wanted to see but I
did just got a slack notification at
3:59 p.m. saying that this budget for
this billing account has exceeded the
point eight threshold and that that
billing account has these three projects
associated with it and I can click here
to link to the billing account so that
worked that's great I'm gonna try one
more which may have the same behavior as
the last one but let's see what happens
if I hit the 90% threshold here get
another message see if the logs show
anything this time oh I'm in the wrong
thing I'm in the wrong thing here we go
thank you okay so it looks like we got a
message there was a notification for
this budget and it looks like it's
calling a cloud function called stop
compute instances oh and it looks like
it stops some instances so Wow let's see
if that really happened
we have compute window open here and we
want to be in the demo account and it
looks like those two instances are
stopped out well that's exciting
let's look at the billing account here
so it still has the billing account
still has these three projects
associated with it but apparently these
two instances as well as there's an
instance in each of the other two
projects they're all stopping right now
and then the end of my demo will be when
I send the 1.0 and let's see what
happens
come on there we go it looks like we got
a notification it looks like we exceeded
a hundred percent of two hundred dollars
and now we're hitting the disable
billing function and then we have
successfully disabled billing and when
we go back to this billing account and
we see which projects are associated
with it
there aren't any so that worked that's
amazing okay we can switch back to the
slides now right you're back
that was what I just did so announce you
all right we've left a ton of time for
questions unfortunately I wanted to give
a quick shout out to some of the other
sessions on billing Lukas alluded to
some of the other functions that are
available for billing so if you missed
it this morning this managing costs in
GCP coming up on Wednesday we have
diving into billing data with bigquery
and data studio so obviously we
published detailed billing data into
bigquery and more detailed billing data
is coming over the next couple of
quarters too so you can do new and
interesting things you can build data
studio templates on top of that as Lucas
alluded to I'm now talking really fast
because we're almost out of time but we
have a we have a billing template that
allow you to dashboard essentially
standardized views within that data
studio template just copy pointed at
your data set and off you go everyone
can become a data studio expert
overnight
and lastly monitoring and forecasting
your cost so that's looking at reporting
we have a showcase downstairs if you
guys want to play around with some of
the financial governance tools that we
talked about there's a few concepts that
they're running through down there
lastly I just want to reiterate there is
no one-size-fits-all as Lucas
demonstrated in his demo you might have
different actions that you want to
enforce at different budget thresholds
and for different environments and so
you need to consider that as you think
about your financial governance strategy
really really quickly because I want to
be respectful of time does anybody have
an urgent question or ultimately you can
come and chat with us after the session
nope okay great thank you
[Applause]
[Music]